we're doing a show in san antonio i  don't know how i forgot this i'm talking  to this kid up front i'm like what do  you do are you a doctor and he's like no  i'm a nurse and the kid next to him is  just completely straight facing me the  whole time like this  and then i'll ask him questions and just  go  and i'm just like this guy's a real kid  and then he pulls out two hearing aids  and i'm like oh  i was making fun of a deaf person for 60  minutes straight he was pakistani whoa  the pakistani family which i thought was  redundant he was a nurse so that's  probably why they beat the [ __ ] at him  because he wasn't a doctor you can't be  a deaf nurse al you were a nurse you  need hearing you think he takes the  stethoscope and puts it over their  mouths